today's episode is sponsored by blinkist
the app that lets you
read or listen to an entire nonfiction
book
in just 15 minutes you can try blinkist
totally free
and get 25 off a subscription when you
go to blinkist.com
david pakman i put the link right below
this video
so i have to start today with
potentially
just a major major scandal and um
the scandal is the growing possibility
that the trump administration
is now lying about coronavirus case
numbers and this is extraordinarily
serious
if true this is potentially
the trump administration doing what
trump attacked
china for doing which china pretty
clearly did do
this this does not mean china didn't do
it this would mean that china did it and
now potentially the united states
is doing it so the number of cases
appears to have flattened in the united
states
since the exact day on which hospitals
were told
don't send your data to the cdc anymore
send it
to donald trump's alex azar
who runs health and human services and
on the day that this happened this
happened july 15
16 i said we now have to look
skeptically at a decline or leveling off
in cases
because now the reporting is going to
the politicized department of health and
human services
instead of the cdc and even more
stunningly as i will show you in a
moment
a complete reversal in case trends took
place
in the states that trump won in 2016
exactly on the day that this change
in reporting took place so there's an
excellent video on youtube about this
by a guy named jeff hester who goes into
a lot more detail than i will today i'm
going to talk more about the political
implications but we're linking to jeff's
video in the description for this
youtube video
so you can see him laid out but the gist
of what's going on
is that on july 16 the first day during
which data
was no longer sent from hospitals to the
cdc but instead
to the department of health and human
services cases nationally started to
flatten
immediately now without looking into
this in more detail
maybe it was a coincidence maybe
something was done
policy wise maybe there's another
reasonable explanation as to why cases
seem to have been
on an aggressive upslope up until this
day
and then right when the reporting change
happens
the cases level off but what jeff hester
then does
is brilliant jeff separates cases and
states won by trump in 2016
and cases and states won by hillary
clinton in 2016
and when you do that what you see
is stunning cases nationally
had been trickling up since mid-june now
it had been a slight uptick in the
hillary states
and a massive growth rate in the red
states about
three times the growth rate in red
states than blue states you had
starting in mid to late june up until
july 16.
on july 16 nothing changes
in the case growth rate in blue states
just that continued
trickle and in red states case growth
actually goes negative forget about
slowing growth they start to see
declines in new cases in trump states i
i need people to really understand this
on exactly the day that the cdc stops
receiving data from hospitals
and instead data goes to hhs and then
comes out from there
hhs run by trump tool alex azar
you have a reduction in the number of
new cases
in the trump states this is a completely
believable slope for blue states just
everything stays roughly the same
slow growth and it is a completely
unbelievable change in slope
in the red states given what we know we
know
that it takes eight to ten weeks to
flatten the curve before you start
seeing a decrease in cases
what you see as social distancing and
mass squaring and shutdowns
work you see the growth rate start to
slow down and that takes four to six
weeks eventually you hit a peak
and then you see the decline start so
in this case we see just a straight up
reduction in new cases in red states
so there's the speculative part but i
don't i don't want to get to the
speculative part quite yet
first let's just focus on what we know
and let's try to find other explanations
see what other explanations we can come
up with
we have cases on a trajectory leading
into july 16
very very large growth we have no real
policy change on july 16th in any case
it takes a couple weeks to see policy
changes
there were no real policy changes around
july 1st
and then on the day that the one thing
that does change
is that data goes from hospitals to hhs
instead of hospitals to cdc
we see that the numbers dramatically
improve
in the red states red state cases start
to decline while there is no change
to the growth rate in blue states what
explanations could there be
other than corruption and lying in the
red states exactly as we predicted this
would leave itself open to
when we announced this policy change
weeks ago well maybe
the red states are being more cautious
but that's not true
red states are being less cautious when
it comes to social distancing policies
and masks and so on and so forth
and again that change would have had to
happen weeks before
to see the effect starting on july 16th
we can get into speculation about the
weather
or humidity but these things have been
widely debunked and they really don't
explain the data anyway
and then you realize and then again this
is still just fact for now
they lie all the time that's just a fact
they lie about crowd sizes
they lie about hurricane maps trump
modifies them with a sharpie
we have the most and best testing 15
cases will soon go to zero not
necessarily a lie but completely
untrustworthy
so we have to consider that this is
corruption and these are fake numbers
and it looks like we may well be lied to
well you could say david you know it's
weird because
even if hhs is doctoring the data the
cdc is reporting the same numbers
as the h as hhs is the cdc also lying
well
as far as we now know cdc is getting
their data from hhs in other words yes
cdc and johns hopkins they're all
reporting the same numbers
because the numbers are now going
hospital to hhs
hhs does whatever and then spits the
data back out which is the data that
everybody else uses so that doesn't
really
prove anything or serve as a defense so
i don't have anything more for you today
in the sense that we need to figure out
what's going on here
it is not plausible that you would see
a reduction in new cases this quickly in
red states
given what we know about policy given
what we know about lag times
and hopefully if there are state-level
whistleblowers that will
be able to shed light into this we will
hear from them soon
and indeed we must call out the
corruption and it exists but understand
that
if they're lying about cases they're
going to have to lie about deaths at
some point
because we know that case spikes lead to
death spikes
and if you lie about only the cases all
of a sudden your death rate relative to
cases is going to go way up
so if they're lying about cases at some
point they're going to have to lie about
deaths
just not testing doesn't make this go
away not reporting deaths
certainly doesn't make it go away but
for a desperate cornered president
who sees himself as potentially losing
to joe biden
i would put nothing past him to try to
win this election
given that we've caught him lying what
twenty thousand lies and misstatements
per the washington post
extremely disturbing and exactly as we
worried would happen
when this policy change took place so as
we get into the middle of the week
this week we are now really just five
weeks from the start of the first early
ballots and absentee ballots in various
states
so i want to have sort of like a very
sober conversation with you
so that we don't all end up surprised
and devastated on november 4th
if donald trump wins we would obviously
still be devastated but i don't want us
to be surprised
despite all of the polling that we've
been looking at
these great polls for joe biden in
states nationally et cetera and we'll
look at some of them later
donald trump can still win re-election
here when you look at
the historical precedent it looks really
bad for trump when you look at being a
hundred days out in past elections
no incumbent has been re-elected with
this level of disapproval
combined with the level of chaos in our
country and in our economy like it looks
historically disastrous for donald trump
trump can't get past 40 percent approval
two-thirds of the country thinks
coronavirus is getting worse
unemployment is at 11 percent
trump is under water in just about every
battleground state trump is mishandling
the three most important issues to
voters today voters
say the most important issues are
coronavirus economy and race relations
and they prefer biden over trump to
different degrees on those three
issues and yet trump can win
now of course we all know there could be
a so-called october surprise and a lot
of the questions i get about how trump
could win are
what kind of october surprise could turn
it around
okay we get a cure and vaccine and trump
takes credit for it and some people fall
for it
maybe trump lies about coronavirus
numbers to justify reopening the economy
and the economy improves even if
temporarily and trump gets credit takes
credit
okay you know trump cures cancer or
something like that trump goes to war
either with another country or with law
enforcement uh in portland
or or chicago as we are seeing but the
thing is
we don't actually even need a so-called
october surprise for donald trump to win
what can happen has a lot to do with us
and a lot to do with donald trump so on
their side
continued anger at the way trump has
been treated trump has
argued he's the victim he's just treated
so terribly
and some people uh will fall for it and
they could actually say
i'm going to turn out because trump has
been treated so unfairly
only in some of those close key states
and trump could eke this out i'm talking
places like
north carolina pennsylvania florida
places where there's certainly a lead
for biden right now but not necessarily
an overwhelming one
then add to that that the polling could
be slightly too favorable to joe biden
so this is not the polls are wrong
but imagine that the margin of error
which is there for a reason
skews towards donald trump so when biden
is plus four
he's really plus one right now so if
biden's really plus one you don't need
that much
for it to be a trump win by a small
margin like we saw in a bunch of states
in 2016.
when biden is plus three right now maybe
that's really a tie
and that could push this even closer and
then the left could do self-inflicted
damage to itself
i talked yesterday about you know let's
postpone some of the policy
disagreements that don't make a
difference right now
until after the election let's focus on
winning as an example i mentioned the
debate between medicare for all
and a public option important debate
significant debate
so important to so many people's lives
but in the next three months it doesn't
do anything for us
biden is not in favor of medicare for
all most senate democrats aren't in
favor of it
and with trump we're not getting either
medicare for all nor the public option
so
what's the point of debating that for
the next three months when the focus
should be get out the vote
the most important thing we can do is
run
as if we're three points behind i'm
sorry run as if we're
10 points behind but vote as if
our vote could decide the states in
which we are voting i know my vote's not
going to decide massachusetts
but i'm operating in the mindset of my
vote is as important as it would be
i'm taking it as seriously as i would
if massachusetts could go one vote to
trump
or by one vote to joe biden if we all
actually do this we could end up with a
historic rebuke of the republican party
not just the white house but also the
senate if we don't
the devastation on november 4th is going
to be overwhelming
vote early vote absentee if you can i've
already requested my absentee ballot
consider the betting websites which
generally
tend to give joe biden about a 60
percent chance of winning right now
remember
hillary on many websites had a 70
percent chance in 2016
and she lost so joe biden having 60
means
trump has 40 those aren't great odds for
anybody to decide to stay home if
when i see those numbers i don't say
i'll sit back and be an observer here no
i'll be a participant so the message is
trump can win
trump can win trump can win no
complacency
no smugness or satisfaction from the
polling data
the polling data is a signal that tells
us we have an opportunity
that's the way i see it north carolina
looks like it's biden plus seven i'll
talk about that later
that means biden has an opportunity in
north carolina that's the way we read
the polling
until election day that's all the
polling tells us which is why
this has to be the message until
november 3rd
let me know your thoughts on twitter at
d pacman
we will take a very short break and be
right back
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
[Music]
what if you could read 10 books in just
one sitting that's exactly what one of
my favorite apps lets you do it's called
blinkist and what they do is take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
they condense them down
into text or audio that you can consume
in 15 minutes
blinkist makes sure that you're getting
all of the
important core insights from each book
so it's perfect for exploring a book you
otherwise wouldn't have time for
if there's a full book you're thinking
about buying you can use blinkist to get
a sample
first just think how much you can enrich
yourself
by being able to soak up an entire
nonfiction book
in just 15 minutes i recently read a
brief history of time of course by the
great stephen hawking this is a book
that i have been aware of for so long
and
other things got in the way and it was
fantastic
to check it out on blinkist blinkist has
books on politics philosophy science
they have 27 different non-fiction
categories and a subscription
is only about eight bucks a month and
you get the entire
library but you can try it totally free
and get 25 off a subscription when you
go to
dot blinkist.com slash david pakman i've
put the link
right underneath this video
[Music]
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
today's new members of the day are
richard steinbeiser
and ralph ernerson arnerson that's kind
of difficult for me to say
also want to say thank you to greg doan
greg
is today's longtime sustaining member of
the day has been a member for almost
five years
really appreciate your support and you
can of course grab a membership
very quickly very easily very simply at
joinpackman.com
we have some stunning new polling
numbers which should serve to do nothing
and
other than to reinforce the opportunity
that we have to remove donald trump in
november if
we all get out and vote this is a
stunning new poll out of north carolina
which puts
joe biden seven points ahead of donald
trump
this is not a democratic-leaning poll in
fact it gives biden a bigger advantage
over trump
than two recent left-leaning polls from
change research and ppp
which respectively have biden plus one
and plus four
this poll of registered voters says
biden is winning by
seven and as we approach election day
i've said before we will see a
transition from registered voter
models being used in polling to likely
voter models
and what's interesting is that the
admittedly democratic leaning
change research poll is a likely voter
model and may actually be more accurate
than joe biden's lead in north carolina
if indeed it exists
maybe significantly smaller than the
seven points
that we have most recently seen on
average joe biden's lead in north
carolina is now
three now as a reminder in 2016 donald
trump
won north carolina by a little more than
three and a half points and
certainly losing north carolina would be
a really bad signal for donald trump
and one that you know depending on the
numbers we might know about relatively
early on november 3rd
north carolina being on the east coast
voting closes earlier
than a lot of other states and if it's
not even close in north carolina we
might know that
very early in the evening and that would
be an important signal about the way the
election is going to go now just as
important out of north carolina based on
what we were talking about
yesterday the democratic senate
candidate cal cunningham
has a nine point lead in the same poll
over the incumbent republican senator
tom tillis
this would be a huge victory this would
be tremendous in the context of
democrats maybe taking the senate as we
were discussing yesterday
so now it's time for a word of caution
that is different than my warning from
earlier about everybody has to vote and
trump can win
that was a general sort of word of
caution now i want to be a little more
specific
we see joe biden winning on average by
almost eight points in florida
six in wisconsin eight in michigan seven
in pennsylvania
four in arizona this should remind us
that we
can't underestimate donald trump
remember that in 2018
a record number of republicans voted in
the midterms
and because democrats also had record
turnout we picked up a bunch of seats in
the house
so if democrats in 2020
and left-leaning independents merely
match
prior turnout we could easily lose
so as we see these numbers as important
as they are as
signals about an opportunity to not only
defeat donald trump and maybe take the
senate and grow the majority in the
house
we should be reminded that when
republicans see this polling
they may become more vote motivated to
vote some may write
these polls off as fake polls but not
all of them
meaning we need to not just match
but exceed our biggest ever turnout and
i believe we need to dramatically exceed
it
as we approach november if the
administration
is indeed lying about coronavirus
numbers if
you see successful efforts to restrict
absentee voting by mail
close polling places federal
paramilitary troops
intimidating voters like if you add all
of this stuff up a little bit a little
bit a little bit death of a thousand
cuts
we need not just to exceed prior turnout
but we need to dramatically exceed prior
turnout in order to not
allow this to be a missed opportunity
maybe trump won't get out the vote great
we benefit
okay maybe trump won't be able to
suppress the vote because judges or
who knows will prevent fantastic
whatever we can't control that and so
what we can do
is vote ourselves and get out the vote
and make sure that we are
so overwhelming turnout that the dirty
tricks
can't work there will be dirty tricks
we're already seeing them there's no
question that there will be dirty tricks
the question is will they matter because
if we really boost turnout in a way that
typically nobody does everybody talks
about boosting turnout and rarely does
it does it really happen
to the degree that i'm thinking about
and many people are thinking about only
if we do that
can we say the dirty tricks won't work
the dirty tricks won't be enough
and that's exactly what we need to hope
for now in the meantime donald trump
i don't know if this is a good strategy
i'll talk about it
donald trump is just insisting the polls
are fake
and that may actually be a
counterproductive strategy for him i'm
going to talk about that next
so yesterday donald trump flew to north
carolina i covered it live
on our various live platforms the new
strategy
appears to be straight up indefensible
lies
that are totally divorced from reality
no longer even trying
to couch the lies as being even remotely
or plausibly believable
trump was asked about the fact and it is
a fact
that he's behind in the polls nationally
and he's behind in
important states and trump just responds
i'm winning everywhere and he doesn't
just say i'm winning everywhere and
leave it at that
trump actually lists states in which he
claims he is winning despite what the
polls say
take a look at this visibly sweaty
donald trump
lying uncontrollably once again mr
president your whole number
suffered in recent months because of
your handling on the pandemic you're
here now today
what's your plan going forward to prove
to americans that you're the right
person
i think the poll numbers are very good
uh the poll numbers we have are very
good we're leading in north carolina
we're leading in pennsylvania we're
leading in arizona
our numbers we're leading in arizona
we're leading
nicely in florida i think our poll
numbers are very good
we're leading substantially in georgia i
mean
we get a lot of suppression polls we get
a lot of fake polls just like we have
fake news i mean it's a terrible thing
when you look at it but i had the same
thing four years ago
now i've said listen today i've spent
what a bunch of the show
reminding you trump can win yeah trump
can win but
here he is simply lying poll numbers are
good
i'm leading in north carolina he says
he's leading in pennsylvania arizona
florida
in georgia substantially the numbers
right now averages
in these states are that biden's up by
four in arizona
biden's up eight in florida which is
incredible trump is up by three in
georgia i don't know that that's
overwhelming but he's up by three
biden's up eight in michigan biden's up
3 in north carolina biden's up 7 and 6
in pennsylvania and wisconsin
respectively so of course
donald trump is lying but my question is
is this a good strategy for trump from
the standpoint of get out the vote and
what i mean by that is
if trump's followers believe trump the
polls are fake and trump's winning
aren't they less likely to go out and
vote in other words
if you want trump to win are you not
more motivated to get out and vote if
you believe
trump may actually lose your state now
i'm not giving them advice i'm thinking
out loud
wouldn't trump be better off saying
something like
we are taking the campaign seriously in
every state
i plan to fight for every state because
i think
i'm better for the people of all of
these states than my opponent
rather than saying we're actually
winning because it seems to me that
saying we're actually winning
might suppress his own turnout i just
don't understand the strategy and maybe
it's not really strategy it's just
trump's personality trump's narcissism
and trump's delusions of grandeur that
force him to do this
now later on during the same event trump
hilariously says
how could i be losing florida there's a
whole bunch of boat owners
in a man-made lake that have trump flags
that they are flying proudly take a look
when you look at florida as an example
you have thousands of boat out about
boats out of the ocean out on the
intercoastal
you look at other states where likewise
you have thousands of
boats and they're all waving the trump
sign
trump pence sign and they're so proud
thousands and thousands you've seen it
where you have bikers for trump with
lines that are miles long on highways
going along
on weekends i think there's more spirit
now
than there's ever been for my campaign
and that includes 2016 where obviously
there was great enthusiasm great spirit
we had
great spirit i think there's more today
because
what we've done nobody's ever done
before nobody has ever
rebuilt the military cut taxes the most
in our history
created the greatest economy we've ever
had the focus on
bikers and boaters is just weird maybe
trump doesn't understand
polls versus anecdotes i don't know one
other key moment from this short
question and answer period that trump
did and
this is a common thing trump has brought
back the coronavirus press briefings
but he takes very few questions very
very few and of course he never
actually answers them trump was asked
you know when you spoke to vladimir
putin
earlier today did you bring up the
russian bounties
and of course donald trump would not say
you did talk with russian president
vladimir putin and
i wanted to ask if you did bring up the
reports
of russia having bounties on
our soldiers and afghans we don't talk
about what we discussed but we had
plenty of discussion
and i think it was very productive
please trump offhandedly just dismisses
it as i don't talk about what we've
discussed
that's not true i mean often you do and
often there are
readouts where we learn what it was that
was discussed
and in this case trump isn't saying what
i'm hearing is
no donald trump did not call vladimir
putin out
about russian bounties obviously and
that story has been very well buried
i've posted on twitter
a few times over the last month what
exactly happened with the russian bounty
stories
the responses from the right tend to be
something about a conspiracy i i don't
know it's obama committed some crime
tends to be the response not very
coherent uh but the story has actually
been successfully buried and
we are going to make an effort not to
allow that
to persist make sure you're following
the david pakman show on instagram at
david pakman show
i really am overdue for a new urban
garden tour
my zucchinis are out of control i've got
10 inchers 8 inchers out there i've
actually
already picked one it's crazy my cukes
are starting to come in
my tomatoes are like nothing anybody in
my backyard has ever seen before
follow me on instagram at david.pakman
for the latest
from the urban garden if you care about
that sort of thing otherwise
right after this short break coleman
hughes
joins me next for what i am sure will be
a very interesting discussion the david
pakman show
at davidpakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show depends on your
support and the easiest way
is through membership which includes the
world famous bonus show
as well as commercial free audio and
video streams of the show
just for members sign up today at
joinpacman.com
coupon code saves you 40 percent vote
soon 18.
welcome back to the david pakman show
today i'm going to be speaking with
coleman hughes who's a fellow at the
manhattan institute and contributing
editor
at city journal also host of the podcast
conversations with coleman uh thanks for
doing this i i've been
hoping we were going to be able to do
this at some point and i guess the time
is now
glad to be here thanks for having me so
i guess to start with for the
portion of my audience that's not
familiar with you or your work
in preparation for this interview i was
seeing you know things written about you
things you've done your podcast etc
and frequently you're referred to as
a black conservative intellectual
is that term conservative being ascribed
to you
do you consider yourself conservative
does the traditional left-right spectrum
even really mean anything to you at this
point or is that are you
sort of operating outside of it maybe
i'm curious
whether that sort of um word resonates
with your views
uh no i've never thought of myself as a
conservative i
grew up during the bush era
laughing at the you know the craziness
of the religious right
instinctively and instinctively
identifying as a liberal
and uh i find many of the things i
say are things obama would have said in
2007 or 2008
um and
so no i don't uh there's lots of
conservatives that i've read and admired
there's lots of liberals i've read and
admired but i don't think of
uh you know what i say and
my ideas as being either
liberal or or conservative i i don't
really think
too much in those terms when you look
right now
and this will probably serve to get us
into some of the things i've
you know you've been commenting on
lately
when you look now at the political lines
that sort of exist in the united states
either around the police protests that
we're seeing
these issues of troops in portland and
other cities and
you know different folks either focusing
on the legality and constitutionality
of protests versus troops and others
focusing more on the reasons for the
protests
does anything in particular resonate
with you
from any of what is in the sort of
political discourse and
or does anything particularly repel you
or seem to you as
misguided or incorrect
um you're speaking about the discourse
coming from protests
yeah coming from catalyzed by protests
but not necessarily strictly from the
protest stores but from the entire
discussion of this issue in society
so what resonates with me about the
discourse that
is catalyzed by protest is the
frustration with the fact that police
aren't held accountable when
they mess up or do wrong it's not to say
they are never
held accountable but they are generally
not held accountable
you just look up any news story of a
police officer
shooting uh you know someone
regardless of their race regardless of
the race of the officer or the person
shot
the odds that they were even disciplined
much less
uh prosecuted is close to zero
um and the only the only times that's
not true
is when a cop does something like shoot
someone in the back while they're lying
face down something truly
where there's truly no possible
justification so i resonate with
that kind of frustration with wanting to
get to a place where those kinds of
things happen
never or extremely rarely um
i don't resonate with the
uh you know the general
the general attitude towards the cops as
bad people or as racists
i don't think i think that is untrue
um i think you know
broadly the i've been to several black
lives matter
protests for example and the the typical
chants are like nypd suck my dick
and that's something i i have no
really i have no
sympathy with i don't i think it's um i
think it's ridiculous
needlessly antagonistic and serves
nobody
i also don't resonate with the you know
the defund
idea i think that's sort of misplaced i
very much resonate with reform smart
reform
so that's a picture of kind of what i
resonate with and what i don't
one thing you mentioned which i think
might be interesting to hear because
there's so many debates about who is
racist and whether something is an
example of a racist individual or a lef
or a racist symptom or a
a sort of racialized vestige of
something from the past
how what's a good way to determine
whether an individual
is racist and do you is it possible
because sometimes i'll read a position
that says
really what you're talking about is mind
reading if you're trying to figure out
what even if
even what someone says wouldn't
necessarily tell you
what is deep in their mind and so we
have to focus merely on
the social repercussions of a policy and
getting away from talking about whether
an individual
is racist question one is does racism at
the individual level
matter in terms of the way you're
looking at these issues and number two
how what's a good way to think about
whether an individual is racist
um i think so
the word racism is a moving target it's
not unique
there's a lot of words like that or what
it means 60 years ago isn't what it
means today and
you can you can fight that but at the
end of the day that that's how language
works
we're always sort of updating these
terms
so i think but that does present a
problem because if you want to have a
deep
a deep and a an opinion on
what it means to be racist that survives
even a 10-year time period
you have to find some other way of
thinking about it other than just
accepting
you know the zeitgeist and i think the
important the way to do that is to
to ask of any particular person what
kind of world do they want to live in
if they had the power what would they
make american society look like
would they want it to look like the jim
crow south
or even less extreme would they want it
to look like
uh slum living conditions for black
people and
uh you know kind of less than
you know a kind of less
formalized but equally severe
segregation or would they want us to
live in an integrated and wealthy
society where people have lots of
opportunity that's the important
question so if you if you fall on the
right side of that question
i have trouble calling you any kind of
racist
or i have trouble thinking of you as a
racist
in in any sense of that word that should
really matter to me
ethically even if you like
laugh at a racist joke or like you know
have some kind of subconscious bias
because i think frankly almost everyone
does if you could if you could have
a perfectly transparent look into every
person's mind
as bill burr once said you know if we
did that on friday we'd all be fired by
monday if
if we're being honest i think so the
kind of racism i'm
that is worth worrying about is is the
kind of racism
that gets the wrong answer to the
question of what kind of world you want
to live in
are there specific systems in the united
states right now
that meet that criteria for you that you
think have to be changed and i guess the
context of that question is you said
in your expression of the frustrations
you have with policing
you said you it is not at the top of
your list that
a large swath of individual officers are
racist so maybe to go further is is
there some system that you believe in
practice
is even if not by definition racist
is having a racialized effect today
which you believe needs to be changed
so i guess my top candidate for that
would be the war on drugs
um in in practice
what it has meant for various reasons um
not all of which have to do with racism
but in effect you know the effect is
sort of the same
what is meant is that a lot of young
black boys
you know spend a day in jail come into
contact with the system
over having an amount of drugs that
is truly negligible and that
if it were a wine mom smoking weed in la
no one would no one would care
there's been a you know at any given
time
very few people in prison are there only
because of weed
but because the sentences are so quick
and people just spend a night in jail
there is a revolving door effect where
just
over over time huge amounts of
of people go in and out over things that
shouldn't be crimes to begin with and
that embitters them to the police it
embitters them to the system
um and it it's horrible for
the relationship between the cops and
civilians i think a lot of cops don't
even want to enforce those laws
it's a drag for them um
so that and it's fallen
disproportionately on
black and hispanic men in particular so
we can go into the reasons for that but
the reasons are less important than
realizing that it it's not serving our
society
and understanding that we should
end it as much as as quickly as we can
if you think about reforming that
specifically
i've not heard you talk about this in
particular but it's something i've been
reading about and i'm wondering what
your thoughts are
there's a lot of discussion about
traffic enforcement as a catalyst
that opens the door to a lot of those
war on drugs type interactions
where there's a significant amount of
discretion like you're talking about a
wine mom
versus a young black or hispanic kid as
an example
so there's a lot of discussion around
traffic enforcement
where you could be if the if the officer
decides you could be let off with a
verbal warning and no inquiry about
searching a vehicle or if the officer
decides maybe they say this is the
vehicle i want to search or a tail light
out or this type of thing
do you think traffic enforcement may be
a focus
where we can eliminate an area of
significant discretion among officers
that could lead to these disparities
so i'm curious what that would look like
in practice
but by eliminating officer discretion do
you mean having someone else do the job
or do you mean
having them follow a kind of stricter
rubric so the two most popular
things i'm reading about are either or a
combination
of replacing a lot of traffic
enforcement not dui but a lot of traffic
enforcement stuff with cameras
uh stoplight infractions speeding
infractions of certain kinds etc
or having some different
part of or non-police individuals
handle certain types of traffic
enforcement either or both of those
ideas
so i like the first idea i mean
selfishly
as a driver who you know occasionally
wants to speed like like everyone else i
think
the idea of having a more certain
enforcement of it through cameras is
obviously unappealing
but from the point of view of society as
a whole like obviously a
camera is going to do a better job it's
completely unbiased
it's also more a more certain kind of
punishment
certain i mean like in in that you're
going to get punished 100 of the time if
you
if you if it catches your license plate
which means that whatever laws it's
enforcing are going to be better
enforced
uh so to interject one thing there
coleman the way in which the cameras
could be biased
is based on where they are placed and
obviously you can imagine ways that you
choose the selection of where the
cameras go
that could still have a very biased
effect
right and i imagine that would be in the
hands of state and local authorities
which might vary wildly in their
competence yes
um so yeah there is definitely
yeah anywhere that humans are in the
chain human error and human bias is
possible
it's i guess it's a relative question of
whether that would be better or worse
than the status quo
it'd be interesting to test it out in a
particular location
as for substituting someone besides the
cops
for you know pulling people over
i don't know i i think
i i i'm curious why that would be better
or why those people wouldn't encounter
wouldn't be subject to the same errors
and um and um
beyond errors like injustices that cops
would perpetrate
and why they wouldn't be subject to the
same
uh um
the same sort of challenges that cops
face
you know you you look look up a video of
youtube
of a cop trying to pull someone over
pulls down the window shoots and leaves
instantly
whoever whoever the cop whoever we get
to do the cops job
is going to be stuck in the following
situation one they
want to do their job if they're a good
person they want to do their job
without needlessly
harming the person that they're pulling
over
two they understand that even if one in
every
thousand people they pull over is
psychotic
that means if they do their job long
enough they could get a bullet in their
skull
and they have to treat every interaction
so as to guard against the past the one
in a thousand possibility
a cop gets shot something like 300 cops
get shot every year
um in america which again not a huge
number but
you know just you know 50 unarmed
americans getting killed
every year changes the way that
civilians
feel when they see a cop certainly 300
cops
getting shot every year changes the way
a cop feels when he's pulling over a
suspect
even if he knows he is not likely to be
one of those 300
so whoever we get to do the job is going
to encounter
what i'm saying is the job it's not an
accident that the job
is leads to these kind of things yes
there are the horrible bad apples like
like derek chovin but more broadly the
job is
inherently difficult because of the
nature of the job
we're going to pause my conversation
with coleman hughes
there and we will post the entire
discussion to the youtube channel at
youtube.com
the david pakman show we'll go to a
quick break and be back right after this
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show depends on the
support of our viewers and listeners
and one way to keep us going is through
patreon
where you can pledge as little as one
dollar per month
or as much as you want at patreon.com
slash david pakman show great perks and
benefits as well read about them
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
so donald trump recently changed his
rhetoric on coronavirus and reportedly
it is uh not because he realized this is
a serious problem
it's because a aids explained to him
that his
own supporters are getting sick and
dying
last week we sort of noticed a change in
donald trump's tone on coronavirus like
as an example
he restarted these coronavirus press
briefings and at the first one he
regularly uh pulled out his mask he has
the mask with them sort of as a prop
now talked about the importance of
wearing masks that it may get worse
before it gets better which
you know any admission that anything
that everything is not perfect is kind
of a big step with donald
trump who has suggested everything's
fine since the start of this pandemic
however it seems as though the reasons
are different than the ones maybe we
imagined our initial analysis was just a
simple
trump's desperate he understands
he's losing in the polls despite
publicly insisting that he's not
losing in the polls and the polls are
fake we
actually know that internally trump has
been furious about polling in which he
is losing to joe biden
but now according to a new poor report
from the washington post
people close to trump claim
that the reason trump's tone has changed
on coronavirus is because advisors have
brought him maps
and they've explained that our people
as they call them trump voters are
disproportionately getting sick
and dying and they actually showed trump
some projections that if
we continue to see these spikes in
battleground states minnesota
um not so much a battleground state
anymore
wisconsin michigan et cetera that it
could disproportionately
hurt trump because it would be more of
his
supporters that might end up getting
sick and dying now there are a few
things here that are completely
outrageous
the first is again the total lack of
empathy
we know donald trump seems almost
constitutionally
unable to experience empathy and indeed
if one thing
uh gets him to change his tune on
coronavirus it's getting told
that his own voters may be the one that
died from the virus
it's another indictment of donald
trump's personality and morality and
total lack of empathy but
the really wacky thing here is i've been
asked essentially this question for
months on friday
questions on live calls via email
voicemails people say you know david the
leftists are
more likely than the right wingers to
wear a mask
to observe social distancing to take the
virus
more seriously is it possible that this
will lead to more trumpists dying from
the virus
and maybe affect the election in
november now
it's of course theoretically possible
and even plausible
but the numbers to flip a state would
have to be really bad to the point where
you have such a degree of death and so
much
more among would-be trump voters than
would-be biden voters that it could
really
impact the election results but it seems
that this is actually becoming a
consideration within the trump campaign
republicans
ignoring guidelines that are being
followed
by democrats could kill
just enough additional republicans that
it hands donald trump a loss
in some state in november and what's
notable there
is the partisan difference in the care
that different people are taking
and the seriousness with which our side
is taking the virus and it's becoming
politically relevant
this is really no different than when
you know an anti-gay republican
changes their view because they have a
kid who's gay or
a nephew or a niece or something like
that
it's just on a grand scale trump is
changing course
when it finally impacts him directly
out of personally selfish reasons and
november
could be an absolute rebuke
of this absolute lunatic and we've got
to take
the republicans in the senate down with
us
because this is nothing short of a death
death cult at this point and
they have to be voted out on november
3rd there's really no other alternative
and what has finally gotten trump to pay
attention to coronavirus
is that his supporters may be dying
at greater rates than democrats are
dying and you know a few people emailed
me
they said if trump loses in november
he will always have coronavirus as the
excuse trump will say
i handled coronavirus beautifully i was
the victim of circumstance and the
reality is that
it is true in a literal sense
and trump will never realize and
certainly never admit that he was simply
a disastrous president his delusions of
grandeur
his narcissism would not allow anything
else he'll say he lost because the virus
happened during his presidency
the truth is actually quite the opposite
national emergencies
often strengthen the incumbent and
there are many world leaders right now
who are more popular than ever
because they took this seriously and
they handled it well it
new zealand comes to mind uh finland
ireland there's a whole list of places
trump's approval rating actually went up
early in the pandemic
because of that rally around the flag
effect george w bush benefited from it
in 2001 after the 9 11 attacks
bush squandered it by going into iraq
after a group of saudi arabians attacked
us
trump again had the opportunity
squandered it didn't take the virus
seriously until like 10 days ago
said 15 cases will soon be zero
everything's fine
we have the most in best testing
economies coming back etc etc
this is a president who turned a health
crisis
into an even bigger national catastrophe
and the reality is
had he handled it well he would be
sailing to re-election today
we have to make sure he doesn't and
after all this
if he were to get re-elected we've just
wasted a really
an unconscionable amount of time let's
not allow that to happen
uh so this is unbelievable or maybe too
believable it turns out that donald
trump was never invited to throw out the
first pitch at yankee stadium
which he claims to have canceled it
appears he was simply jealous that dr
anthony fauci was invited to throw out
the first pitch at yankee stadium's uh
opener last week and trump first
said i will be invited and i will be
doing it soon then later he said he was
going to be too busy
this is actually the clearest
explanation this is not the most
important news story but it puts
together
a bunch of really important things one
of which is donald trump's
jealous disdain for dr anthony fauci
which led to trump tweeting nonsense
about fauchi in the middle
of the night last night trump completely
lacking focus on anything
important during a pandemic while he's
golfing tweeting
and being jealous of anthony fauci and
thinking about first pitches
but let's get caught up first so we all
know what we're talking about last week
donald trump claimed he would be
throwing out a first pitch
at yankee stadium on august 15th trump
then tweeted canceling it
saying quote because of my strong focus
on the china virus
including scheduled meetings on capital
v
vaccines our economy and much else i
won't be able to be in new york to throw
out the opening pitch for the yankees on
august 15th
we will make it later in the season and
i speculated
trump's worried he'll look stupid
because he looked really dumb throwing a
baseball around last week he doesn't
want to be ridiculed for a bad first
pitch
or trump doesn't want to get booed like
he's been booed at other stadiums which
was just wrong of me to say because
there's no crowds right now at baseball
games
or trump doesn't want to be rebuked by
all of the players because
overwhelmingly major league baseball
players have been kneeling during the
national anthem
if trump's there while that's going on
that's not going to look particularly
good for trump
i was over analyzing the truth is there
was no first pitch
there was no first pitch to cancel trump
made it all up when trump announced this
his own staff knew there was no such
thing on his schedule
the yankees knew there was no such thing
on their schedule what happened was that
trump was so
jealous of anthony fauci that he told
his staff
call up my friend at the yankees and
tell tell him i want to throw out a
first pitch there was no actual date
behind the scenes chaos ensued and
ultimately trump ended up canceling an
event
that never even existed with the tweet
that i showed you earlier
and it all goes back to trump's
uncontrollable
jealousy it's really envy of dr fauci
when trump said he was invited to throw
out the first pitch
it was an hour before dr fauci actually
threw out the first pitch fragile trump
was triggered and was just lying that's
it that's the explanation
should this surprise us no the lying
certainly should not
trump likes uh uh to lie regularly about
easily disproven things you know the
size of his
crowd coronavirus testing he lies all
the time about everything
the really dangerous part is the
weaponized
jealousy of dr fauci fauci's a doctor
and trump isn't
and yet trump is in some kind of bizarre
competition with fauci
as if they have equally valid opinions
on medical issues which
they don't i should i can't believe i
have to clarify that but
they don't trump is petty to the point
of being delusional
and that has been normalized over the
last three years remember when trump
tweeted
you know time magazine it was something
like time magazine called me and said i
was probably going to be man of the year
person of the year or whatever last year
but i would have to agree to do like an
interview in a major photo shoot
and it's i'm just too busy so i passed
completely made up i mean just
fabricated out of thin air then trump
ended up being mad
that greta tunberg ended up being times
person of the year
it's all insane it is weaponized envy it
is delusional ignorance
uh it is a global laughing stock and we
i'm not even going to say it you know
what we have to do
we do it in three months and then we
move on and we start returning to
normality normalcy normality i prefer to
say normality despite it maybe not being
a word
we have a voicemail number that number
is 2192 davidp
you guys are going to love this um i
have this furious
trumpist jimmy from philly who calls in
and he is very much like an
anti uh bernie sanders anti-left type
guy
he doesn't like handouts he wants people
to
pull themself up by their bootstraps and
all that typical stuff
he heard that i was getting a new
microphone and indeed if you're watching
today today is the first day with my new
shure sm7b i know it doesn't sound
perfect yet but
we're working on it and so jimmy called
and he said hey can i have your old
microphone for free take a listen to
this
david jimmy from philly i hear you're
getting a new microphone
right uh how about let me have the old
one
i'll pay shipping yeah so uh
jimmy wants free stuff what has jimmy
done to earn
my evre20 which i've used for
10 years if i'm going to get honestly
we've been thinking should we auction
off i've used that microphone for 10
years it still works perfectly
i could sign the microphone with a
sharpie or not i mean if people don't
want it
we could auction it off for example
and do something interesting i'm going
to send it
to a furious trumpist who i've had to
kick off of my phone lines
for his virulently homophobic statements
that's who i'm going to send a 500
microphone to so jimmy first of all why
not figure out
how to pull yourself up by your
bootstraps and get yourself a microphone
you don't have to spend 500 bucks like
on an evr e20
micro you can get a 20 microphone okay
jimmy so that's first of all you don't
have to come
begging me for handouts and number two
if i'm going to give the microphone to
someone i'm not going to give it to
someone who calls in and says such
disgusting things you know i appreciate
hearing from people from all sides jimmy
and
your calls are welcome but a free
microphone
come on it seems like it's a little bit
of entitlement
that i'm hearing there so no uh maybe we
will auction it off and maybe jimmy will
win
but i am unable jimmy to send you a free
500
microphone i apologize for that on the
bonus show today
donald trump has signed an executive
order or
executive as i've heard some people say
i say executive order
on drug prices a planet fitness
a gym chain is now going to start
requiring
members and guests to wear masks in
their gyms at all times this is
infuriating a lot of gym goers and we
will also talk about what some are
calling hygiene
theater hygiene theater now i'm not
talking about masks but i'm talking
about
some other elements of hygiene that
there are even
medical experts saying this is hygiene
theater if it makes us
feel better okay but from the standpoint
of
actual science some of the things that
are being done or recommended around the
virus
are merely theater merely optics we will
talk about that on the bonus show
as well how do you get access to the
bonus show
beautiful perfect question two ways
number one
get a membership at joinpakman.com
number two
become a patron at patreon dot com
slash david pakman show you can get the
bonus show
the commercial free audio and video
streams of the show
and so much more today later today
i will likely be live streaming if you
want to join me on youtube or twitch
and very exciting we are scheduled to
surpass
900 000 youtube subscribers today
by the time you hear today's show listen
to this
episode we may already be there and
then the race to a million begins and i
will talk to you more about that
on an upcoming program
thanks so much for watching today's full
episode of the show just a reminder
today's sponsor is blinkist the app that
lets you
read or listen to an entire non-fiction
book
in just 15 minutes you can try blinkist
for free
and save 25 percent off of a
subscription
when you go to blinkist.com david pakman
i've also included the link right
underneath this video